6 24 here it is a beautiful Thursday
morning and we're talking now about a
special vegan dinner with wine but for a
good cause we have Brad Brown joining us
here from Crossroads kitchen Shania
Graham from Southern glazers to talk
about unlvino Bon vivon dining and we've
got some wonderful little dishes here as
well but first let's talk Brad about
unlvino it's been around in Las Vegas
for such a long time the support and and
the help that events like this can
provide it's you know we're excited this
is our first time to work with them so
we're super excited we actually just
opened a Resorts World in May and we've
been looking forward to being involved a
lot in the community so we're very
excited to be partnering uh with them
yeah it's great and unlvino and what
UNLV has for its Hospitality programs is
is so uh is so unique and what's
interesting here is we're talking about
a vegan all vegan uh options here for
this particular event correct so you
know that's what crossroads is where
that kind of Crossroads between you know
flexitarian omnivores vegans so you know
we do our Chef tall Ronin is is the uh
kind of the penultimate guy when you
talk about vegan food and and taking
items
that you wouldn't think were necessarily
vegan in his interpretation so what we
have right here is literally a chestnut
in porcini foie gras with a Cabernet
Demi some walnuts
um a little grilled sourdough bread so
that kind of traditional Vegas luxury
dish but done in a vegan style very
tasty in southern glaze is of course you
know you can't have this without some
some good wine some good beverages it's
important to make sure you have a good
pairing with something like this as well
yeah so we have Gerard petrans
biodynamic wine world famous coming in
and pairing up with them their wine
makers will be there to talk with Chef
tal Ronan so we're super excited we'll
also have some students on hand to talk
about you and alvino and all the
exciting events coming up yeah unlvino
goes on there's a lot of events at
unlvino of course this is just part of
it if people want to take part in this
uh sample some of the food sample some
of the beverages as well how can they
take part
um unlvino.com it says all of the events
all of the dates and you can buy tickets
straight from there and all of the
proceeds go 100 back to the hospitality
college for scholarships which is
excellent and great to see yeah we
appreciate both of you guys for coming
in this morning looking forward to
talking into that potentially this
morning here uh we appreciate it so good
stuff there and you and alvino another
great event it is